well first of all king f4 we thought
it's a draw yeah look what's going to
start with he went f4 but this is an
amazing way of winning if it's winning
to come back
to e5 it's a completely study-like
position and i guess the idea after
bishop g4 is bishop b7 and white's king
is better place than it previously was
but
is it okay
it takes time for us to understand
well this is not good i think it's the
idea to play is it king e4 after bishop
e2 maybe
g4
but now it takes black longer to
push the f pawn right because king e3
and you need to still move the bishop so
maybe bishop b7 here bishop
c6
f2 ah and i take the corner
wow
um i mean this is deep this is
incredible idea for magnus dawson
it's hard to believe that it's a win
it's but already just the try itself is
amazing to me and magnus has 56 minutes
just in case for all the calculation he
needs so now it is really all about uh
it's very difficult for firuza who would
be thinking that in move 25 30 when we
reached out this completely equally
bishop and game probably it's a win
because the black king cannot be
reaching to d6 yeah faruzia looks
flustered as well on the camera just
scratching his head
after this game he will not forget this
game for a long time but it's really
reminiscent of their game in norway
chess last year in this king and pawn
ending he just needed to find the
opposition find the right square for his
king and because of the clock panicked
and
self-destructed so and this is a swan
yeah black's bishop stuck at home
bishop v7 coming next magnus is trying
to going here and the the distance
opposition and so on
but in this position i think in this
game it was very different the problem
that uh
in one hand probably he was hesitating
well it's a bad road then he didn't was
not sure about it but actually it is
such an exemplary position because if
you just go back
to really it was moved 24 when we
reached this position so he's plenty of
time
and this shows how well you have to be
structured and
very very focused that if you have a
drawish position because in this
position there was only one weakness of
the game
a6 pawn it was only one and with one
weakness you should not lose the game
and
little by little magnus with his magic
he was just being extremely patient
so it is very clear that ali rezab will
know that he will be focusing on end
games desperately because this this is a
and you cannot say that that it's it
would be a shame to lose this position
because it could happen to anybody this
king d6 king e5 it's amazing of course
he had to be calculating more i think
king f4 should be a draw but
by now i'm not sure about anything
but let's see if this is actually really
winning because now i think
bishop d7 is a good idea
to give up the phone with not having the
king on the eighth in a very passive
position at least keeping the white king
out for now um but magnus i mean he can
take the pawn he can get his bishop out
even if he does it the long way around i
think uh magnus now bishop b7 bring the
white king to d4 at the right moment
push a6
the black king can't
uh kind of hold its ground for the rest
of the game i think so
okay well let's see how let's say bishop
g2 definitely not brushing with that one
okay king e3 i guess okay let's let's
say i went to bishop d5 just to not to
discuss it if you don't lose time sure
okay so what happens here uh but
actually
yeah king e4
black bishop passed
on bishop
king d4 bishop a6
okay so we just need
the last six one for white
somehow
maybe bishop e2
just two yeah bishop a6 is not possible
to bishop f1 and then the black's losing
the opposition
yeah and you're only playing with the
king now
well still black will be fighting jack
here
how about bishop a8 and then king d5
was nicer yeah i thought bishop before
bishop g6 but well white only has to
solve this problem
to rush to
this way so we'll find a way to cross
eventually okay so after bishop e2 black
has to go bishop d7 now ace
a6 i think a6 is not good enough c6 yeah
i can see six
king e3 king e5 a6
king d4 now
yeah he still wins again still winning
okay but he plays kinky for
y to
rush
and only after that he will be taking on
a6 yeah controlling everything and
white's bishop won't be stuck on a6 for
too long
d6 you think he'll wait again kd4 i'm
really grinding out that
tiny minute skill advantage
well this is the trademark of uh magnus
actually sure how many games he wanted
and then he's just having his patience
that's how he works
for like hours
he doesn't want anything actually it's
not that i think he's playing really for
a win he's just curious to see what is
the position yeah patient as well
slightly statistic in that he likes to
talk to everybody but yeah he's mostly
patient enjoying the moment
has 11 seconds which will be not the
biggest problem for him yeah
actually for real just trying to think
back to where he even allowed any
chances i'm surprised he
left why play g5 in the first place
yes because then the only way i mean
white can never create any slight
imbalance in general
divorce so yeah i mean obviously he's
got the endgame knowledge maybe just the
thought process could be
no but this is absolutely brilliant when
he plays king e5 yeah yeah i mean
beyond our radar right just yeah
it's human instinct to just go for the
pawns because you can go for the bishop
but yeah and also imagining where phil
firoza can go wrong because obviously
the end game was drewish he didn't have
i think we can say that he didn't have
anything
maybe zero zero five
maybe a five percent chance of winning
if
yeah but you're not expecting at this
level that you have real chances to win
because you have to make plenty of very
small mistakes yeah i mean what you said
h5 h6 and f6 not to allow g5 that's kind
of probably the best after you allow g5
it's still not the end of the world sure
but then already you're sure the larger
for error is kind of yeah it's getting
uh you are have to be more precise and
eventually probably maybe after instead
of f4 king f4 was only
yeah
if it was i'm not sure anymore
but i think this imagination hits the
nail on the header psychologically it's
hard for furuzio when he knows okay it
was a two result game for the whole time
despite the fact he should make a draw
and
knowing that suddenly he needed to be
super accurate when that pressure wasn't
on before
okay meanwhile
a few moves have been made white's
bishop has tied down the black bishop to
its pawn and
at the right moment where i can just
push a6 maybe that moment is now
okay no not yet no rush
but after bishop e4 and bishop moves
away then a6
yeah and actually that's awesome
there we go
i have a feeling that you'll have a
similar smile on magnus's face because
he knows that well maybe not
he'll save that smile for us maybe
he'll be very happy about this